Gear for you?
One,
all of your world records drug free.
Yeah,
I remember seeing a jug free,
uh,
I a jug free for 37,
38 years.
But I did try,
I did try roids uh,
in 1980 or 81,
I believe it was.
Well before it became illegal.
I tried.
What'd you try?
I try and I went to a doctor and I dunno if I should say this fucker's name
cause he might still be busy,
still viable.
The same doctor that Arnold and uh,
uh,
all the guys who were in the magazines,
you know,
I thought everybody was drug free.
I didn't think,
I didn't think nobody talks.
It's a weird thing about those magazines,
right.
Nothing to cry.
Branched chain amino acids.
Yeah.
Oh fucking man.
I couldn't wait before I get,
some of them will meet her ass shit man.
So they got me for sure.
That's what he was thinking about.
Uh,
uh,
I want a couple of little contest and a guy,
the guy who was promoting context,
it came to me and said,
what are you taking CT and a half,
28 arms,
you know,
then I didn't,
I thought everybody had thought every fucking buying it.
I seen those magazines are honored.
Everybody else was drug free.
He goes,
what are you taking?
And I told him to amino acids and shit.
And he goes,
Oh man,
what,
what kind of steroids are you taking?
I said,
what's that?
And he said,
you don't know what a stair radius.
And you didn't even know what,
I didn't even know what the fuck he was.
So he told me,
you know,
you gotta go to this doctor.
And uh,
and,
uh,
gave me the address and everything and he said,
I don't know if I'd say the doctor's name,
but I still remember.
And,
uh,
I went to the Dang thing guy looked at my nose and ears and shit and listen to
my lungs and gave me a prescription for,
uh,
decker.
Yeah,
it gave me a prescription for some decades rivaling.
And I take it right,
the Kaiser Pharmacy and a pharmacist.
Uh,
I said,
you know what this is.
And I said,
yes,
fucking steroids are thinking.
He said,
yeah,
it's bad.
You don't need this shit.
You know what?
Look,
I want to give you it.
I want to be a professional body building.
They told me if I want to be a professional and be like Arno and Franklin rest
guy,
I got to take this shit.
So I want to take it.
And he gave,
he gave it to me.
We grudgingly feel prescriptive.
I took it home and I take my decade,
and then I went back to doctor [inaudible] and he gave me no picture for a
testosterone.
So I took Deca and testosterone.
And did you notice a difference?
Fuck yes.
I know that the difference.
I know you got off of it.
Yeah,
I got off of it,
but I had a,
I had read,
I had reasons.
And you want to Jv with those words?
Sure.
Okay.
It worked.
It definitely worked.
Uh,
I got fucking hard.
It's,
you know,
just Titus fuck.
And,
uh,
but,
I'd also,
uh,
I don't know if it does,
it does this to everyone.
People when I told him I tell him about this sometimes and I Nice you,
you must've been an ass hole beforehand.
And that's quite,
quite possibly true because I was a pretty much an asshole because the way I was
raised,
you know,
I had a bad attitude going in.
So when I got home sees it and it seemed to amplify my bad attitude and my
editor a short fuse,
like this is a fighter.
UFC fighting him short fused.
Yeah.
Well I should have had that nickname way before.
Head hurt me man.
Cause I had fucking short fused big time and everything.
Everything pissed me off.
So I had a really bad attitude.
I was married at the time,
you know,
I had a real bad attitude and my wife and she couldn't do shit wrong,
I mean nothing minute and,
but okay,
that,
that was part of it.
And another big,
big fucking thing with me is what I love more than muscles and lifting weights
and fast cars and I love all that shit.
It's sex and a big giant,
big old giant.
While I rolled over to have sex and nothing was happening,
I said,
fuck these steroids.
But these days when you got off of them told me,
Oh,
you got to take this,
this other shit to make this
dead.
Anything,
anything.
Donors
fuck it.
Fuck it.
Oh No,
no.
Anything is going to do Amy,
I wrote to be a 110 pounds soaking wet and still be able to,
you know,
get my boner.
Uh,
fuck that.
You know.
So it must have affected your lifting too,
because what it comes is just a giant dip in your natural testosterone when she
get off of it.
Oh.
Oh,
it's bad,
Huh?
It was the,
because I,
you know,
I decided,
hey,
I'm out.
Fuck this shit.
Fuck this shit what you want for a total of six months.
But what they do is they told us back then you do two months on,
two months off.
So it took longer.
So I do two months on it.
Take two months off,
two months on tomorrow.
That was the protocol.
Yeah,
that's it.
That's what they told us.
That's what doctor,
whatever his name is,
uh,
talk,
talk dude.
So it was told six months but it took longer.
Nigga,
they had two months off in between two months old and um,
uh,
that stuff it fucking definitely,
definitely.
Uh,
but when you,
what they don't tell you is when you stop taking it shit,
we just stopped taking it cold Turkey like that.
Every fucking thing that you gained during that time.
And I came,
I was ready for,
I had one little small body,
Boone County,
cause I thought I was ready for fucking Mister America after this shit.
You know,
I'm like,
Oh fuck,
I'm,
I just got so much tighter and it had a more veins and shit than ever.
And I'm like,
Oh man,
this is great shit.
But when you get off this shit,
everything that you came,
you lose it.
And then some,
I lost it.
Any strength gains that I might've might've gang got from it or any,
you know,
the harness at me.
I had to start from lower than where I was before I started taking it.
Cause you to stop time.
They say you do gain something and you keep something once your body normalizes,
you know,
you do have some sort of gains.
That's one of the arguments that they say about people that have taken steroids
and gotten off of them.
That if you can normalize your testosterone,
you're still going to have an advantage over people that have never taken it
before.
I don't know.
I'm genuine.
I don't know how true that is.
I felt like that,
uh,
every single thing game then I promise,
man.
I think I,
I mean I felt like I lost ground actually.
Uh,
cause I just stopped cold Turkey and I think I actually lost Brown.
It's still supposed to wean yourself off and stuff.
But you know,
but I'm telling you when I roll over,
you know,
I'm fucking 21 years old and I thought that sex every day was the normal.
Right.
I mean,
you,
you just,
that's what you getting married,
safe every day,
man.
That's one of the benefits.
And if I don't,
if I can't have sex every day,
then you know,
hey,
something's wrong.
Fuck this.
You know,
so I just,
that was my normal normal thing.
And I'm probably pretty sure that my wife at the time probably didn't think
that,
but I was like [inaudible] we this motherfucker and you know,
that was a,
she had a break when the steroid things,
we got a little break for the first time ever,
you know,
who was married?
Like,
you know,
oh no,
no,
no.
Anything that's going to fuck with that.
Fuck.
That's what gets people back on it.
A lot of,
yeah.
You couldn't get psychologically addicted,
of course.
I mean,
uh,
who,
I mean,
you,
Jack and I talked about it,
you know,
and I was,
I was interviewed and magazine articles and stuff a few times when I was world
champion back Lena.
I brought it up in the art cause I never thought it was anything that high,
you know,
or anything like that.
I said,
yeah,
you know,
I,
I wish that I had never done it.
I wish I could say,
now I'm going,
if I look back,
I wish I could say I have,
I have a perfectly clean record.
Like my,
my training partner,
Richard Sherman,
where for 20 we've trained together for 20 years and this guy,
perfect record,
never even tried it.
Well,
he was stronger than me.
He was his,
his mind was stronger than my eye.
Peer pressure and wanting to be in the magazines and wanting to make a living,
doing something that I love is did a punch punching the clock every day.
Now that appeal was too great for me as a young guy for me to pass it up.
I wanted to do something that I love and make money at it way back then.
But I why not working at the Post Office for 28 years?
Well,
it makes sense.
I mean,
it definitely makes sense that the appeal would be so strong and it's a,
it's a very,
it works.
I mean that's the big reason why people want to take it out of sports.
And I don't know if he ever watched that documentary that's on Netflix called
ICARUS.
Have you seen that?
No,
I haven't seen increments.
ICARES is all about the Russian,
uh,
anti-doping state sponsored program.
The Russian,
well I should say pro doping.
Oh,
Yay.
You go literally gave steroids to every single one of their athletes.
More things.
Yeah.
It's a crazy documentary man because the guy,
Bryan Fogel,
who's the director is also,
he's in it because he was an amateur cyclist and what he wanted to do as an
experiment.
So he ran it or he cycled this race one year,
totally clean.
And then the next year he went to this Russian doctrine,
said just fucking juice me up to the gills.
Like,
let's do this.
And they just shot him up with everything.
And in the process of him getting to know this doctor,
the scandal broke out about the Sochi Olympics,
about the Russians cheated during the Sochi Olympics.
And it's all documented in this film as the news is breaking.
And then the guy who's the Russian doctor has to flee Russia.
He leaves his family behind.
They take his family's house and they take all their money and they're basically
making this family homeless to try to get him to come back to Russia.
He's in protective custody and America right now.
And he detailed the entire program.
Everyone was hot.
Everyone.
Everyone was on something.
They want 13.
What's hilarious?
They just took some of the metals away and the metals they took with the most
bullshit metals like gymnastics.
You can have this one.
Like they took like four bullshit battles away,
but they kept the big reveal.
Yeah.
They kept wrestling.
They kept
date once
it's bullshit and deed.
I did see big,
strong fast.
Yeah.
Um,
uh,
that's pretty sick take.
Yeah.
Right.
Because they're pro steroids.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
That is interesting.
A pro steroids and a lot of people.
Yeah.
Well the,
the argument is,
I mean,
uh,
see,
I see it in the terms of fair competition.
I see the argument against it for fair competition.
That makes sense.
But like,
I also see the argument in terms of like,
if you're going to be taken amino acids and creatine and all these different
things that do give you some sort of a benefit,
why don't I take the shit that gives you the real benefit?
Well,
I,
you know,
uh,
I,
I don't find a fault with people who would be side to take Roy's because like I
said,
I'm 21 year old kid and,
uh,
I took,
so how the fuck can I talk shit about anybody who's who to make the same
decision?
And then I did that many years ago.
You know,
I,
I'd be a hypocrite ass hole if I was,
you know,
to do that as long as everybody in the competition that you're in,
whatever that competition might be,
if you fucking flipping ties or whatever,
whatever the fuck it is,
a tech and grab whatever fuck it is.
If everybody else in there is doing it,
then,
then it's a level playing field that,
but when you got guys that are trying to compete naturally,
right against guys that are not,
then it becomes unfair.
So,
uh,
if they,
if they have a division and they do it in a lot in these weightlifting contests
and things,
now they have divisions that are called natural divisions and they actually test
for steroids and stuff like that.
And maybe I should do something like that for the fighters.
You ain't going,
we ain't going to text you guys if you want fuckers.
He'd just come on in here and whatever you bring went Bree,
Bree,
when she got kind of doing that in Japan.
Yeah.
Japan has an organization called Reisen where it's essentially an offshoot of
pride,
or at least some of the people are involved.
They were involved in pride and pride.
Like I had an ensign.
Anyway,
on the podcast,
he was talking about his pride contract.
He said it specifically stated we will not test you for steroids caps and shit.
Damn fucking animals.